(audience cheering)
- Oh my gosh. You look so sharp.
- I, do I?
- Yes, from the socks. I love
all of it, the shoes, yeah.
- Oh, I know. Look at those socks.
- Yes!
- The color.
- All of it. It's nice.
- This feels like I'm in your living room.
- I know. That's the point.
We want you
- Was this furniture
to be comfortable.
- in your living room?
- No.
- Okay.
- But I am not, this is Kevin.
They've actually won
Emmy's, my art department.
My house isn't this cool.
Like I would not win Emmy's for that.
So, but how's your 2023 going? Is it good?
- It's going quite well, yes.
- Do you do, like, do
you make any predictions
for yourself or try and set any goals?
- I don't want to disappoint myself
by breaking any of the resolutions.
- Yeah.
- I wanted to just,
I've been working a lot for
the last 20 some odd years.
- Yeah.
- So I wanted to do something
that was just more fun and light,
and see more of my
hometown Los Angeles more.
- Yeah.
- And get to the museums
and go-
- Isn't it funny
where you live you never
go to any of the things.
- It's the truth.
- Yeah.
- I know people who have lived
in New York City all their lives
they have never been to the
stature of liberty ever.
- I know people as well.
And I did that like as a sophomore
in high school on a trip.
Like, it was like what?
- Yeah, exactly.
- Yeah, I was like, how
have you not been there?
- We do, we take it for granted,
what is available to us at any time.
- And it's cool now, I think
especially with like Ancestry,
like 23, all those things,
to know I had relatives
come through there.
That's like so cool-
- Yes, yes.
- To know and to see those names.
- I know, I know.
- It's nice.
Well, you grew up around
Los Angeles as well,
do you think that influenced
you in wanting to be an actor?
- Well, possibly. My parents were actors.
- Well, that probably influenced you.
- That influenced me quite a bit.
It's like the family business.
They met doing the Betty White Show.
- What?
- Many, many years ago.
- Wow.
- Yeah.
And they fell in love
and then got married,
started having kids and there you go.
- Oh my gosh.
- I was born in Hollywood.
I was raised in the San Fernando Valley.
- So you always knew you
wanted to be an actor?
- No.
- Okay.
Acting is is a very delicate business.
- It's fickle.
- And if you don't have
the right temperament for
it, it could hurt you.
- Yeah.
- We've certainly seen
a lot of examples of that where people
don't handle it correctly.
- It can swallow you up.
- Yeah, their ego gets too
big or they get too depressed.
- They can't handle the pressure.
- Too high, too low, and you really have
to maintain a nice steady foundation.
And I always tell young actors that.
It's if you want to try this business,
get your personal life in order,
make that your foundation.
- That's great advice.
- And then you can fly.
- Really wish somebody
would've give me that advice
when I was getting in.
Yeah, I'm just saying that
would've been helpful.
- That would've been
nice. (groans comically)
- I mean, cuz it's like, it's funny though
'cause this industry, like most artists
can be a bit manic in our personalities,
so it's a hard industry for
that kind of high and low.
So I think it's really great advice.
- You need to steady it out.
So no, I went to college thinking
I was gonna become a police officer.
- Really?
- Because that was
a formidable job and a respected job,
and that's what I was gonna do.
I actually took, I was
in the police explorers
when I was 16 years old.
- Yeah.
- And I realized I had
an aptitude for it, but I
graduated first in my class-
- Wow.
- Of 111 16 year olds
at the LAPD Academy.
That's cool.
- When I was 16.
And so I thought, "Whoa, I
guess that's what I'm gonna do."
- Yeah, you excel at it.
- Yeah.
- But it wasn't what I loved to do.
- That's the difference.
And you have one life, so really push
for the things you really wanna be doing.
- Yeah.
- There was something
in the back of my head
saying, "Are you sure?"
And yet if you're good
at something, you think,
"Well, that's what I should follow."
- Yeah, what's the
moment then that happened
that you were like, "Acting
is really what I wanna do"?
- I was on the Blue Ridge
Parkway in Virginia.
I was on a motorcycle
and it started to rain.
- Figuring out life.
- And I got off
the Blue Ridge Parkway
and went down this little
picnic area.
- Oh my god,
at first I thought you were being funny.
- I'm telling you the truth.
- You are being-
- I'm am telling-
- I thought you were being-
(audience laughing)
- I thought you were being funny,
and I was, "Oh, this is a real story."
- Yeah, it's a real story.
- Okay, yes, okay.
You're on a motorcycle, super cool.
Okay, so you pull off
because it's raining.
- I'm 21 years old.
- Okay.
- And in those days there was no GPS,
and so I didn't know
when the next town was.
It is getting a little too dangerous.
I pull off, get up on a slab of cement,
four posts and a roof and a picnic table.
And for the next six days,
that's where I stayed.
- It rained for six days?
- Six days.
I was starting
to build an arc.
- An arc?
I was getting. (laughs)
- It was so, and I don't know.
- Try building an arc-
- Figure this out.
- Out of a motorcycle
and a picnic table.
- Have a little pole barn, yeah.
- It's not easy.
So, so during that you just
had, that's kind of cool though.
I think life works out like that.
So during that you had time to
you had to just be
still and figure it out.
- I was reading
- That's nice.
- I was reading a book of plays,
Hedda Gabler, at the time.
- Yeah.
- And, and I,
and I was, I finished it and I realized
I started reading it in daylight
and now it was nighttime.
And I thought, oh my God,
how did I miss the transition
from day to night?
And it was because I was
taken away by the, the power
of storytelling.
And I thought at that
moment, okay, I'm going to
try to become good at something
I was really falling in love with.
- Yeah.
- As opposed to
doing something I was good
at, but not in love with.
- Yeah. That's a great lesson.
You should write a
book, all these lessons.
Like we should stitch on a pillow.
What did you do to make money?
Like while you were, because
we all, I was a waitress.
I had like many jobs, but I feel
like we all were waiters at some point.
- Always.
- Yeah. I definitely had-
- Were you good at that?
- Waited tables, you
know what I was good at?
I wasn't great at the
actual etiquette of waiting,
picking up and dropping
off and doing this.
- Yeah.
- I was good at
observing if a couple wanted to
be entertained or left alone.
- Oh.
- And, and, and I was good at noticing-
- Reading the room.
- Reading a room.
And if we were late in getting
the food out, I would just
bring them some French
shrimp cocktail or something.
Like, I'm so sorry, here's
some something free.
You know?
- Yeah.
- And they were very grateful for that.
So I, I kind of made up-
- That means you're a great waiter.
That was, yeah, I want that waiter, yeah.
I feel like that's a great waiter.
- Well, I didn't wanna be a waiter
- Distract me while I'm
waiting on my food. Yeah.
- And I also, I also loaded trucks
in downtown Los Angeles.
- Yeah.
- Andy Garcia was one
of the other guys down there loading.
- And doing it, doing the same thing.
- Yes ma'am.
- That's so crazy.
- Hard work.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- And then I was a videotape interviewer
for a dating service
called Great Expectations.
- The dating service
was Great Expectations.
I feel like you're setting
yourself up for failure.
- No, those expectations better be great.
- Did you reach them?
I know. I'm just like,
wait, so wait, so here's the thing.
We got wind of this and
this is my favorite thing.
So you mean this service?
Roll the tape.
- You made a smart decision
by joining great expectations.
Now keep your positive momentum going.
Make sure to keep your appointment
for your photo and video
and set aside some time to
read the Great Success Workbook
in your new member kit.
- Here's the thing.
You were revolutionary
because here's the thing.
Now all these apps do exactly this.
- That's right.
Like, just in an app world,
you were ahead of the game.
- That's right.
You would, you would
slide right or slide left
but you didn't do anything.
And those days, it's like
now it was the precursor
to all those, you know,
match.com and things like that.
- I know.
- It actually worked really well.
- Did, I was gonna ask, did couples really
come together on that?
- And got married, and-
- Wow.
- Yes, they did.
- Okay.
- So the show is just such
a huge hit, Breaking Bad.
It's 10 years now since the finale.
- They're happy it's over.
- No!
- Yeah.
- It's such a huge show.
Like in pop culture.
Like, I don't know anybody
that didn't watch it.
It's just like one of those shows.
And like, is it true that you
got a tattoo when it ended?
Have you not had a tattoo yet?
- I had not had a tattoo and the day it
ended 10 years ago, I, every,
all the crew were talking
I'm gonna get a tattoo.
- Yeah.
- So I just hired a tattoo
artist to come to our,
our wrap party and I was the
first one to get a tattoo
and you can see it right here.
- Oh, okay.
- Right, It's, it's the symbol for...
- There.
- Yep. Yep, yep.
- Am I doing that right? There you?
That one?
- At first I was like
which finger is that when
you're pointing it at me?
- That one.
- Because I have one, I
have one on my middle one.
- How dare you.
- Well
- What is, what is
- He wasn't nice. You don't wanna know.
- Oh, we don't wanna know the story?
- Um, yeah. He's a horrible man.
It's just a reminder to, you know,
don't go don't open that door.
- Yeah.
- You know what he should do
is put a mustache on it
and a black eye on that thing.
- Yeah. It wasn't a great one
but that's why it's on my middle finger.
Well, I wanted to also talk
about your showtime show.
So it's called Your Honor.
- Yes.
- So tell everybody
about what this is about
if they haven't seen the first season.
- Your Honor is about
a superior court judge
who is a very honorable man
and he has a, a teenage son
who gets into a car accident,
leaves the scene of the
accident, which is a crime
- Makes a poor decision.
- Yes.
And I come home, he tells
me about it and I say
you gotta do the right thing.
I take him to the police
station to turn him in
and I discover that the
boy who was actually
killed in this accident
is the son of a mob boss.
And I know with every
being in my, in my soul
that that man would kill my son.
Yeah. So on that moment
of, of decision, I decide
not to turn him into the
police to protect him and
with the conceit of if I did,
he would, he would be dead.
So everything starts to
spiral out of control.
And that's the first season. Now,
- Yeah
- we're in the second season.
- Yeah.
- What happens?
It ended tragically, I'll just
say that in the first season,
second season, I wanted to
explore what would that feel
like if all, if that loss
of a child, God forbid,
what would that feel like?
And so Showtime was willing to go in
and explore that.
- Yeah.
- Of grief and despair and
- That's real.
- It's real.
And is there a life after that?
And so, but I will say that this season
with all the excitement and tension,
it ends up in a different
way than the first,
first ended in tragedy.
This ends hopefully.
- Hopeful?
- Yeah.
- Is that hard?
Like I, I know you're an
actor, you're all acting.
I get it.
But is it hard when you
are a parent to do scenes
like that when you have to
go to that place of like
what if I lost my, I don't,
that would be very hard.
- I, I did a scene on Breaking
Bad where I was watching
a woman die in the second season and
being prepared for that.
And all of a sudden her
face left and the face
of my real daughter showed
up and I was watching
my real daughter die.
- Yeah.
- In front of me.
And it choked me.
I even get a little choked up.
- I know. I'm like, I'm tearing up.
Don't do that. What am I gonna
- Do about it now.
Yeah.
- And, and it, it, for about two
or three seconds I saw my
daughter's face choked me up
and then that went away
and Kristen Ritter's face came back and
- Yeah.
- And there she was.
And, and it was like, oh my God.
And it is, it is emotional
risk that actors go through.
We have to put ourselves in a position
of vulnerability for that to
possibly happen because you're
you're willing to go
into the unknown really.
Yeah. Yeah.